Little Mix in the sick don't have to
listen to your album actually did last
night all of it I absolutely loved it
yeah yeah I wasn't sure what to expect
but it is so good I got to tell you what
my favorite song is my pit is awesome
it's such a great song I love it so so
you guys to be here I think Canada's
going to just absorb you and just really
love everything you do and just the fact
that it's called glory days are you
living your glory days right now late
today
literally like last year dishes in the
fact of using our career so far I would
say like I was the same to the girls I
feel like every year we're taking
something off our bucket list which is
amazing yeah a very year I think it's
all images been to go for five years now
since X Factor and there's some growing
pains that comes with it ray linking
them together what's that in the
beginning of the development or do you
find that the growing thing has happened
in the recent years and I don't anything
happening yeah actually being alright I
mean the only pain we probably had was
for me to be a state out and we had a
big struggle to end out there so often
that like spanned rise people's or in
believe us for we are we society how do
you do that you guys like color each
other's Mini over here behind me did you
bring our gender nature's best friends
yeah and we've just fell lucky because
they'll do that something's very rare
and that doesn't really happen very
often but we are we're just best mates
like 15 you're like litter and we just I
don't know how we just get on everything
yeah so that's really weird as well so
like none of my days I look I quite like
to be on my own more than awhile I was
like me time which I think we were kind
of mean here but like this morning or
inside seniors
today gossip I just sleep you're my way
yeah but you I mean I'm straight yeah
like yeah do any of you guys actually
have to search yeah yeah you may just
want to put it is because you want to
jump yeah you guys are a massive success
for overseas and you're here you are in
North America and making your name for
yourself do you feel any pressure of
getting that same success here or are
you just letting a beat I mean I want to
say no but yes we do we want it so much
like more than ever and we are
determined to willing to do anything
anything like it and then I remember
what completely want to say as much as
possible and to really crack it because
we thought we've done everywhere else
misses are what we need to do yeah is
the main break maybe she called Raven oh
right right where's yeah you like great
yeah right right now you think what I
find interesting in the UK is that you
guys deal with the paparazzi you deal
with a lot of stuff there yet was there
anything that really just kind of fected
you that was happening down there and I
think like obviously when we first
started out we weren't used to it like
to be thrown into lovely like we were
just thrown into this industry and cut
to get used to everything so yeah we
were really young at the time it was
horrible being packed and not knowing
about in and seeing it's like on the
front cover of a magazine and you're
looking awful no girl wants a sword or
suspected you not what they're writing I
mean anything really but now like I said
we've like growing a thick skin for
everything and then I thought we've
taken enough anymore and I think I look
what old are words we're more confident
in ourselves and they're spending on
want the publishers discussing pixels
and they're like yeah we can't change a
lot you can do about it comes with it
yes I learn to love yourself and yeah we
get to claim and do that right